[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to our monday night
show I hope you are not totally
exhausted from watching this thriller
world championship game and if you're
not be ready for some funky blitz games
I can absolutely assure you that I'm in
terrible shape because that game was
such a snoozer I actually played a
couple of games and I really played
badly so I'm hoping to improve so the
warm-up games were done of stream hope
I'm doing better now solo the game start
arrested and playing in deep
independiente ok Grandmaster okie dokie
so independiente oh not a six haha
against that I'm not going to play the
form it's a tricky little line so what
is he doing a line we're a six makes no
sense at least it makes little sense
okay I can just play normal development
moves okay is it already time to punish
him my probably not they're just
complete development cancelling looks
all good Bishop g4 maybe I want to
prevent let's do that and yeah yeah
Bishop e3 as normal i think i'm going to
do that just develop normally is Knight
a5 the thing here maybe
95 looks annoying to me I don't want to
give up the bishop maybe I have to ok
let's centralized how I don't don't
quite like this and it should it should
be ok actually I don't think I did
anything particularly wrong but some of
this position feels uncomfortable yeah I
played six games before that for the
stream and I managed to to take 100
points I was on 2500 and now I'm not and
I don't like to give him two bishops in
against two nights doesn't take it
that's surprising I would have taken
that in a heartbeat me being the bishop
pair junkie I think it was a good
decision actually to take ok here I try
try this real quickly trading off his
best piece ok I'm ok
for be three in the bank oh yeah that's
a bad move actually I mean all moves are
good the best movies is six though after
that you can actually hope for for an
advantage afters g6 or takes your fine
absolutely fine but after you six you
can hope to win quickly heaven if white
is making any more strange moves what
some good players to study if you want
to learn the caro-kann hmm I think there
are a couple of course um good bats are
German Grand Master Igor genki he's a
very good caricom player you can also
check games by a drea he's played it a
lot maybe not recently I'm not sure he's
played other openings as well there's a
recommendation yessir Sarah one yeah
Anna it's not a bad recommendation yes
also has played the car come quite a bit
so how am i doing this year I don't
quite like the Knights damn i would like
to trade off the d6 night
94 94 I could have taken takes on d5 so
I'm covering this and maybe maybe you
know maybe I have 95 g4 and night h6 and
he will not see the mate you will
probably see the mate though yeah of
course study cop off you can look at
couples games but this is like a long
time ago there's a mention of your
guinea Barea that's true Barea maza or
still is CARICOM player you have to
really you know in the carrel nowadays
it's clear that it's all about the
advanced variation and you you have to
study study this as the most critical
line and I think you want newer games I
mean cop off his of course a great great
player but he's um not really I mean he
hasn't played this kind of thing for in
15 years and you you want something
current because this is a variation that
is steadily evolving so um what's going
on here going to keep this and then
night see for next no I cannot go
Knights it for as he has route d5 know
and this position was very good I wanted
to go 95 ideas rook takes that's a
stupid just plain stupid hmm
ah it was such a good positioning now
I've got nothing here it's a shame or
can I do something else here can i still
continue to attack
I would he hate this it was such a good
position I takes them okay why didn't he
why didn't he take the other one that
that's really strange okay so let's get
going
[Music]
brooke t5 was what was irritating me and
then they placed us in a heartbeat can i
play the Slav against before I can
yeah that's true Sebastian I didn't play
d4 that often recently I was trying to
yeah I get a better grip on various
efore lines and so on trying to be more
versatile so what's going on in this
position it should be good u7 hangs how
old is he cover this he doesn't okay I'm
taking look 27 26 wins but Queenie six
looks very dangerous anyway and Queenie
5 is also on yeah I've got Queen a
seven-time Marty I shouldn't be bad
probably Queen f6 for the moment but i
will take him but how do i finish this
off I mean it looks great but how do you
win actually rookie 1e7 the second rope
that should do it I'm not sure I'm
threatening more like rook age 6 or
something he has screen to g7 so look
rook e1 rookie seven looks dangerous or
maybe the age porn coming up the board
could be something or just D 626 doesn't
really have a big threat coming okay I
try for group c 7 i am i stopping this
that's a good one
so how do I actually win if i should
bring the route back David supported
upon hmm that that really didn't do all
that much did it he wants to check me
here it's not such a big thing chan chan
blundering d6 of all pawns ok I'm still
threatening made and I'll threatening
week which is seven ok it might still be
ok black for XPS and move him yes the
movie it is a complete when we will you
you you that wasn't good but it was away
so let's request in one what's my
opinion for the 12th game and the tie
breaks yeah okay well game 12 was a
complete complete disappointment I
actually was very much thinking that
Carlson was would try to play a little
bit something without risk certainly but
not with that low risk I mean this was
just a complete draw from the get-go and
very disappointing this thing I
understand it from a med strategy point
of view a little bit because I think his
chances in the rapid is a good and I
what you definitely can say that st. in
a star in a rapid game if you do one
it's not such a big deal because you
can't come back there are four games and
you cannot come back from a loss in Game
12 so I understand that wow this is a
really incorrect and give incorrect
gambit I mean completely incorrect so I
actually this is actually good you
should play Bishop f5 ah yeah anyway
come on check I can I can just play
this position and be okay 96 Bishop e6
just developed normally so knight c6
p.m. maybe place no sloth yeah I forget
about it I honestly don't do it on
purpose I simply like play the moves out
and afterward think oh there was a
request so this is not very exciting
here this pollution is g5 an option
let's do it maybe maybe let's get some
activity in a sis got some coordination
issues him so I'm trying to use this he
has a couple of pieces that wow wow that
looks wrong that looks really wrong but
can you exploit it it's the thing like
takes probably not ok I'm taking this
one can i play a car so with black I
should play c6 md5 check you're trying
to say I understand I will try I don't
know 90s maybe tick with a night I don't
know I'm not threatening much here still
no tactics on ok now if I take it h 2
i'm kind of close to promotion with this
I can take we should take 66 look aged 3
doesn't win no
I can play age to immediately though
what is he doing now nothing much and
here checking maybe chat shaking first
so i would like to get this let's trade
check he has a hard time to move
anything here so let's check this do i
need to cover that i think i want to
cover it don't know how though can also
take him
Josh Shakira doesn't really matter um I
usually meet my students on a weekly or
bi-weekly basis so I think this is also
kind of necessary if you do less it's it
should be somewhat somewhat close to
that so M how do i meet him is there a
maid coming here I don't see one kind of
surprisingly
[Music]
my dears to play look at five I assume
it's not trading I have to watch the
time a little bit so what is I should
shake made him somehow but I don't see
it King ASA actually the King a 76 made
so that's getting if I do see six check
that's it looks like he almost made that
didn't work out with the with a check
made so let's try to try to just win the
porn I actually a c6 didn't see that not
a good technical display not really
check
yeah this is actually actually okay but
still not great yeah I don't think that
this this non game was a bad move
strategy-wise it just is very
disappointing that there wasn't even
something tried kind of not paying
enough time more attention to this game
to be honest his classical score was
also was great so so I finally won that
bloody pawn and he got this one Chang
her and I'm get up paying attention he
is king be three hey I'm running a
little bit low on pause I have to say
that something that I need you need to
be aware of and now it checks me here oh
my god that would have been quite
annoying if he would have done that
check not a good technical display how
do i actually do it maybe bring the 95
and then go on the third-ranked yes
still not all that obvious how to do it
in check a couple of seconds check isn't
that some kind of made check no there's
no made check so I'm winning winning the
poor now check oh god damn it yeah I
already said I didn't I didn't do this
well shoot nine seconds oh my god that
will be tricky
[Music]
check check check check check check
[Music]
[Music]
check no I don't manage the same draw
while there was a bad game oh I just
squandered my time there shuffling
around down and then I didn't have the
time at the end game pretty bad okay
spinal tap whatever so let's I mean at
least we get a kind of Kanye with white
so yeah it's it's nice again this is an
interesting porn sack and my opponent is
taking it who is that Tom Bartel okay
I don't quite remember how that world
yeah I don't know my development is good
but it still looks kind of weird mmm
yeah i'm experimenting yeah yeah i'm not
i don't really know all those lines i
know it was hanging but i'm kind of
gambling here now you can probably take
it he can take that ball I think I don't
really have anything brilliant after it
I think he's considering it and I think
you will take it yeah I shouldn't have
done that I mean queen 820 really is too
good for him it's just uh just a bad
position and at least is considering
yeah I mean you never know I played it
reasonably quickly maybe I have
something cool prepared where I don't I
just up wood and it's just a bad
position yeah 95 suggest suggested in
the chat but that's really just a bond
over he placed an idea of six and is
fine I'm not saying that this is
brilliant but this at least prevents the
bishop moves I mean until you have 96
check which is not great but check at
least I'm getting some some half
compensation and I have Borden's media
in some cases Bishop f4 Quincy 6 Bishop
a6 mate which is of course a very
well-known idea so you know you know
ingest you have sometimes tricks and
this is
[Music]
that was very lucky this guy is
currently biting into his desk because
you till I'm the person I wonder the
phone fulbrook get it was I mean fishy
is putting in Marlin but it gotta win
him yeah so King takes check check and
I'm winning the Queen so Knight b6
wasn't a solution to blacks opening game
started face Oh against spinal tap or
does this guy definitely wants to go
after me now let's play another fish
again but if it okay I don't think this
is so fishy but anyway there's a
question in the chat by someone who quit
quit is nicotine addiction but always
feels like there are there's the fear of
falling back into it when when there's
alcohol involved no actually not I don't
really I didn't experience it all that
much I have to say that I also um very
slowly phased out on the nicotine I did
not just like stopped from one day till
the other and I was basically phasing it
out and they're only big withdrawal
syndrome symptoms I had when switching
from tobacco chew to that electronic
cigarettes this is really something that
i found remarkable
how how how big those symptoms were
because I was always thinking that
nicotine is the main thing that is the
addiction course in the cigarettes but
this is not the case it's not just that
there's also additional stuff that they
put put into it and i really had bad
symptoms there with all kinds of weird
things so okay he wants to go night to
be five that'sthat's pretty clear I have
various ideas i think i'm going with
this and I want to prepare a five year
as well yeah each 3 M I am a 3 i'm not
sure what I would have done after that
anyway that's go at five maybe he can
take and play night age for this is this
as possible my main point you was to
undermine d5 night h4 is a problem I
already did not appreciate that fully ok
so I'm going after the d5 pawn that's a
big pond if I can get it I currently
don't see how he covers it not that this
is decisive but it's nice to get a
center pond so I've gotten this one okay
I think just back here
the best line for white against the bank
oh um that's it's hard to say probably
the accepted like the absolute main line
is probably the most critical okay so he
wants to play a 4 here
[Music]
and he will and he will unless I play
night f4 which is a pretty radical
solution but it could be possible it
looks kind of shaky
it was kind of shaking yeah people
always seem to have problems that the
World Championships can be decided by
rapid games altima tlie blitz games I I
kind of understand the rationale but
also you have to see them you have to
see that rapid and blitz is part of
chess as well I mean that it's really
nowadays rather important part as many
events are played and played in that
time control so what is he going to do I
ever take he wants to take these sex
that is strong very strong okay so ah if
i take here take on b5 takes king is 70
s going g3 holy moly that's that's good
wow yeah I felt that there could be
something wrong here and I was not
entirely off so i take night know if I
rook takes actually I would be five so
and 90s the king of six okay always you
just playing g3 here Wow Christ mmm he
plays that
is it take it on d6 now or something it
might work my time I don't know he does
not have to take right away I'm not
threatening to recover everything
anything now I'm out for i know i can
place your phone actually getting rid of
this porn I wanted to do that all along
so let's do it 96 no King e6 it's equal
material so and those points for center
bonds are not so bad I wonder about this
is that really helping them those pieces
look weird ok now if I was under
pressure my idea simply rook b2 and rook
hm time morning it says something else i
don't know i don't know i'm going to
play active moves as usual in the bank
owned trying to double on the second he
might move the night for some checks but
i have f4 i can always escape to f5
going forward now that feels okay
[Music]
okay now i'm shooting for a win i wrote
these sex
[Music]
okay so c7 Wow vu check can I do
something better than just grabbing
probably not now it's a draw
unfortunately and fortunately it is a
draw I was hoping for more check check
game drawn not good I mean probably okay
result I don't know but I felt like I
should be able to do more anyway let's
do form a new one yeah I kind of agree
what jonathan is saying in the chat they
should not have an Armageddon game they
should like continue to play blitz until
there's a decider I I agree I agree
again started okay let's play Rufus 2600
are you serious useless commentary of
games how where does all that okay so we
got a Scandinavian here don't see that
too often
[Music]
I don't know I don't know the theory
yeah i mean i have no big idea something
like that is is a theoretical line that
that much i know but i don't know any
details at all so ship c4 is going queen
e for not good okay i do something
simple him that cannot be the best line
yeah loafers I think he's playing max
maxim drew guiana right I think I've
seen something there so it still this
must be somewhat okay for me check okay
so if i do this how do you cover by
seven long castles I mean f7 hangs not
sure yeah he's not really looking at
this it's kind of tough not to take it
let's do it my queen my queen doesn't
have many squares though this is a kind
of kind of clear and is there anything
funny that I can do anything anything
sharp probably not so I'm try to get the
Queen bag
it took a bit of time but my position
feels solid this is probably the moment
where he where he brings the hammer down
the moment you think of my position is
kind of solid I am and then something
bad happens it is kind of solid down you
know what did I just say that's the
moment when he when he plays some kind
of kind of funky move okay so if i take
with the pawn he's checking me and king
king it's made let's losing the Queen so
I cannot take this that said say you
know this is a cool move here very cool
so what to do the good thing is I'm not
sure that it is threatening all that
much so I can maybe still play but
should be two or something if he takes
on g2 I will leave Bishop f3 you should
be good the rookie is still hanging
and I'm preparing to castle where does
he put the rook actually back I'm not
threatening to take it yeah he goes back
so what's the deal here just castles
should be six I wonder if I should check
here actually but he has roop the aid
that doesn't really do much Bishop f3 is
bad at the screen no Quinn d3 actually
have root d1 so maybe this isn't all
that bad goes down ok so now I cancel
and then I need to bring the Queen
around to the to the Queen side I
actually don't have a bad piece
placement here I just wonder where where
to put it I can go see for ok it's got
Bishop d3 i'll click there this is
actually something i can do but i don't
know doesn't really help all that much
the square yeah maybe maybe I'm drifting
into some time troll which is a clear
recipe for disaster in such a game we
should be three queen is six Bishop f1
Bishop g4 I think it's very good for me
unless I'm overlooking stuff so but this
is he's not going to play we should be
three I think seems unlikely
[Music]
I wonder if Bishop c6 is actually a
threat
no no not at the moment not at the
moment I maybe I can take take a seven
just centralizes okay yeah Bishop d3 now
kind of gets more is more on the rail
more on the map maybe it just takes
between this position rapid
he is drifting into time trouble why can
I not take I don't know okay I couldn't
take that was nothing bad about that if
i take this now no it's not a good move
okay let's just go back don't look bad
you ask me my background is weak I have
to be very time morning cautious with my
back rank this why I'm going here
covering d1 yes okay what
well that's a cheetah come on no human
being plays Bishop d1 what you got to be
kidding me that it's crazy
that's totally crazy come on why is this
guy not banned come on you're crazy he
plays Bishop d1 yeah I get onto my fence
on calcagno just take it I'm completely
lost here yeah you played this in two
seconds yeah great come on as you see
ben de sky he's got how many games he's
got what game started in that come on
there that's it's just a complete joke
okay so let's play Julian auction at
least he's not cheating yeah of course
it's the best engine move it's a killer
move crazy yeah what sean is playing
this line and I still have not lived up
in five this is a simple way of playing
it check they took two seconds for that
killer very obvious move yeah very
obvious ok so I'm playing very simple
check I need to cool down after this
crap Rufus is no title jam where was the
title there was no title where's the
title I don't see it
anyway okay if it's a human or coolness
to him but this is smelled like a
complete engine nonsense yeah in the
meantime we've gotten an ending here
against mr. hodgson not much going on
[Music]
so what's what's going on here probably
not that much
I a bit more space
check f5 interesting check maybe it's
comin around who change eh no it's not
okay can i play for win somehow only not
let's do this this is going to be a draw
I guess yeah this is the drool say
anyway forward from the nokia check
yes youtube channel way plays live then
then who is that guy I mean graph our
third game draw yeah okay then the
brilliant move other all the power to
him but but it is a very computer
itional game started okay playing petty
crook Capri here and let's see what he
does against a bank oh I also be sick so
that's a good line solid line yep one of
the in many ways white can play I'm
happy with black hair people keep
telling me that this line would be
annoying for black but I simply don't
see why maybe I'm not understanding it
correctly but I always felt like I
should be okay in a position like that
yeah yes I wonder what does he have he
has a bad bullet rating on what it's to
cut 2,000 in bullet yes sure and blitz
is 2500 okay
so white has installed a night on b6 who
the heck is Lutz who who is lots who
you're not telling me some unknown
Chinese player right that that's a
genius no you're not telling me that
right I am so in the meantime we have
this game here against PT Capri and he
is trying to get something here it's
gonna light on b6 now oh maybe maybe
this is actually something oh i
blundered that pawn that's not good
that's not good
okay that was very unnecessary the
position was nothing at all i think for
white then let's still fight so long
hmm it's a bad part to lose not so much
for the pawn but it was the pawn that
gave me gave me the b5 square which is
really annoying that I don't have it
anymore I have to do something fishy am
[Music]
very stupid blunder
yeah no it's easier if he if he gets all
this in I just completely lost it just
completely lost yeah then that point was
them was was a backbone of this position
without it it's just not a playable it's
not playable simply you cannot you
cannot blunder that and still have a
position does it work
[Music]
not good can only hope for some very
cheap tricks here Nick Knight c3 looking
for something but that's unlikely to
happen then we are not live
yes so after a longer thought his
Comiskey he came up with this move okay
it doesn't really matter let's take him
I she wonder is that so great what is he
doing a West 97 or what exactly
hmm is that so clear I mean that that
never was the the best way technically
speaking cannot cannot believe it huh
I've pinned myself
[Music]
check yeah this is not fun but at least
I'm threatening Quincy one I mean it's
super cheap trick but you never know you
never know King f1 Queen 86 actually how
we do see prevent that the stuff moving
the room maybe I'm so you're so kind of
kind of him still around and what why
are you not doing something against the
check check Hey Wow
check okay so let's see he's continuing
this why not let's see check that
actually was mostly intended time
morning it actually did not did not see
this anyway check this isn't this isn't
so easy actually in a couple of seconds
okay grabbing here and they are somewhat
dangerous or spawns is 6 so probably
this one check yeah I have to take it
this now I cannot cannot blunder
completely and it still should win
technically
[Music]
not easy still not easy I it's got
Bishop b5 actually hmm yeah then it was
it wasn't all that easy I have no time
it's time to play this on time of course
shoot damn it Jack forfeits on time what
a ridiculous game what a ridiculous game
if we both played like complete idiots
yeah okay so not one one more I cool
Rufus chats with me someone watching
goes team just told me that you think
i'm using an engine yeah anyway game
will start it's something it's something
for me for the complaint team so and we
have Grandmaster our kannada i am and
let's see what he's doing this is a
collie rusty and I think so German gem
what is he doing
get an english i'm putting here that's a
solid sale if i can so long it'll be
really funky let's do this it's probably
nonsense but let's let's do something
funky am I mean he's a gem I hope it
doesn't take any offense in this I it is
it is not really great iam but let's um
let's try to be just compare complete
Rowley and and attack okay so he wants
to take Here I am can I take here first
and then do this Lexi queen bee three
years I is an extremely annoying idea
sometimes
so it keeps this simply basically saying
I'm threatening nothing that might be
true
you
check so what's going on here 94 I also
have the bishop check which she cannot
take but he doesn't need to I'm not sure
94 is probably probably correct anyway
let's do it it cannot take it because of
made and well so this is a move that
defense for the time being so I take it
he takes with the pawn bishop before
Bishop e3 so looks like he has defended
this correctly okay night age six and
yeah it's just it's not going to work
okay i mean this this whole thing was on
the under not too good side but still
and it says something that I can do here
yeah those caveman attack say they
usually don't work for me at least not
in in in blitz a and bullet or so you
can play all kinds of stuff but here
doesn't look like it works
[Music]
yeah this is like totally lost I mean
really totally lost I mean he can attack
himself is the problem that queen bee
three or something and he's got the
attack my king my king has like no
protection so um is there any way to to
get get something here something funky
he's attacking of the rook which is kind
of Jim kind of unimportant okay that
doesn't work yeah yeah yeah I know
you're totally right about all that and
a cream b3 is still killing me now it's
playing it ah yeah I know this this did
not work as I said I tried to tried
something fun funky so let's put this
here unfortunately I'm not threatening
something no not even that yeah I Knight
b6 is going to win here for him
check check check let's made us except
like an a okay that that did not work
not at all yeah okay this nine actually
isn't that bad it just shouldn't play in
that caveman style the thing is that
this is a bad idea I mean what you can
do actually is play Russia ate something
like that and then just play for this
idea which is not so bad I mean long
castles really answer more than more
than dicing okay guys hope you enjoyed
the show whatever it was it was probably
more enjoyable than the world
championship game so thanks for watching
and I'll be back next week regular time
slot and and then we even know who's the
world champion going to be for two more
years thanks for watching guys bye bye
[Music]